Kasey's with us in Fort Myers Florida hi
Casey how are you right now are you
doing better than I deserve what's up I
had a question regarding children
grandparents and money in Christmas
where we have a three year old two year
old and a six month old and so we're
pretty busy around the house as you can
imagine and we're working hard on
raising them teaching them godly
principles how to handle money short
charts trying to be diligent ourselves
in that with them and to be thankful
grateful not to have an entitled mindset
and so as Christmas comes along
grandparents who aren't able to the kids
very much we feel like when it comes
Christmas times sometimes go way
overboard you know with the guests and
so is that something we should just
overlook or is that something that we
try to redeem you know we've even talked
about you know if they give maybe we
take some of those toys back but we feel
like that might be teaching our kids I'm
not being grateful you know to take
those things back yeah so you being a
grandparent no I'm not I was just
wanting to have any information for us
my answer answer today might be more
softer than it would have been ten years
ago and in all honesty and I don't think
the grandparents should be doing it
because I don't think they can afford it
but that's another thing that we haven't
been able to change yet yeah yeah well
you know number one you handle your
parents she handles her parents because
otherwise you're gonna get into a big
problem okay and you know you'd be very
gentle and and what I would say let's
let's start with the I can't afford it
to start with that part of it it might
be that you say to your dad and mom you
just sit down next time they're into
Christmas this time don't worry about
this Christmas it's already here but sit
down when you're with them and go you
know guys we're really working hard to
teach these kids a value of a dollar and
dad you taught me the value of a dollar
you made me work my butt off you
remember that and who are you and what
you do with my father the way you're
treating these grandkids I mean it's
such both of our spheres are that having
that conversation with them would be a
bad because we don't have a problem
confronting that box or lovingly but we
feel like that it would just be a you
know there's the only way I can love
these kids you know you're gonna take it
away from me mm-hmm have they actually
have you actually had the conversation
that's actually what they said are you
just afraid that's what's gonna happen
we we've talked about it and my wife
talked about it was her parents and her
mom gets really defensive and you know
she's always bringing the kids things
and she's this how I can love them I
don't see them and so we've kind of just
we're like on eggshells there okay okay
number one I'm not gonna support a toxic
situation where I can't have
conversations about my kids that that's
a breakdown there that's got to be
worked on relationally but as an
overarching concept if they're not
around a lot they're not going to mess
up your kids you know you know and
they're probably not going to destroy
their personal finances but it sounds
them to me like with what you described
there in in the context of everything
that we're talking about that her mom
has some issues and like some issues and
I love the kids by giving them items
that's your description of love you know
no that's stuff is not love stuffs just
stuff so that and you know I you're do
you're denying me the right to love my
grandchildren old romic done seriously
you know so there's other issues going
on there that are deeper than just
whether your kids get too much stuff and
so I'm gonna set boundaries with toxic
value systems more than I'm worried
about just the amount of gifts but you
know it's a if it's one time a year it's
not going to mess up you're playing with
your kids your kids are not gonna be
entitled spoiled brats because once a
year the grandparents give them too much
stuff that they can't afford to give
them if it's that simple
you're okay but you know I wouldn't
fight it over that alone but it's not
that simple because mother-in-law has
issues and apparently neither couple can
really afford to give at the level
they're giving and and so
you know I'm going to continue to have
some kind of conversation here on both
of those things mother says you grant
mother-in-law's issues and on all of
that we just you know we we appreciate
so much your heart for these kids but
man it's just a little over the top if
you dial it back a little bit you could
afford it more and the kids are been
gonna love you they're you know they're
I don't love you based on how much you
give them and so you know let's dial
this back a little bit it's a little bit
out of control if you'd help us with
that we'd really appreciate it if they
can't hear a conversation like that
there's other stuff going on in this
relationship other boundary issues if my
kids grown kids said that to me about my
grandkids I would have to listen and it
would probably be true this is the Dave
Ramsey show hey guys thanks for watching
if you enjoyed this video click the
subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]